Hi everyone, it's Caitlin Luna, host of Speaking of Psychology. This episode was recorded live during APA 2019, our annual convention that was held in Chicago this year. I was away on maternity leave during that time, so my colleague, Dr. Lynn Buffka, was a guest host. We hope you enjoy the episode. Hello, and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm Dr. Lynn Buffka, and I'm guest hosting this podcast. from APA 2019 here in Chicago. Joining us today is Dr. Kalyani Gopal,
大家好，我是《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）的主持人凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。本期节目是在我们今年于芝加哥举办的年度大会——2019年美国心理学会（APA）大会期间现场录制的。当时我正在休产假，所以由我的同事林恩·巴夫卡（Dr. Lynn Buffka）博士担任客座主持人。希望大家喜欢这期节目。大家好，欢迎收听美国心理学会出品的播客《心理学谈话》。我是林恩·巴夫卡博士，很高兴能作为客座主持人，在芝加哥的2019年APA大会现场主持这期节目。今天做客我们节目的是卡利亚尼·戈帕尔（Dr. Kalyani Gopal）博士，
a clinical psychologist and the executive director of the organization Safe, Sexual Trafficking Awareness, Freedom, and Empowerment. Thank you for being here. Welcome to the show. Thank you, Lynn. Thank you for having me here. I was hoping you could start by telling me
她是一位临床心理学家，也是“安全、性贩运意识、自由与赋权”（SAFE）组织的执行董事。感谢您的到来，欢迎参加我们的节目。谢谢你，林恩。谢谢你邀请我。我希望你能先介绍一下
a little bit about your background and how you came to be involved in this area of work. Sure. I've been in the field for about 30 years. now and I first got in the field of human trafficking probably when I was 17 or 18 without knowing that I was working as victims of human trafficking. Oh wow. At this time I was in India, I was a bachelor's degree student and I was doing my bachelor's degree
你的背景，以及你是如何开始从事这一领域工作的。当然。我从事这个领域已经大约30年了。我第一次接触人口贩运是在我17或18岁的时候，当时我并不知道我接触的是人口贩运的受害者。哦，天哪。那时我在印度，是一名学士学位在读生，我当时正在写关于
paper on research paper on women in jails, so young women in jails. So I went to this jail which is called the Tihar Jail, it's a New Delhi India and I went to the jail and I was collecting data. and the girls were disappearing. So I was the same age as those girls. I was 18, 17, 18, myself, and so were the girls. They were all locked out. There's like 20 girls, 25 girls in a room,
监狱中女性的毕业论文，也就是监狱里的年轻女性。所以我去了新德里的提哈尔监狱（Tihar Jail）收集数据。当时我发现女孩们正在消失。我和那些女孩年纪相仿，我当时17、18岁，她们也是。她们都被关在里面。一个房间里有20到25个女孩，
all locked up in that room. And then they were disappearing in the course of the night. So I used to come back to collect data from the very same girl. Because, you know, in research you're collecting the data from the same group of people. So I go back to collect data, and some of them are not there. And years, and then when I left there, eight months later, they actually had me sign a paper saying that I would not disclose what I'd found in the jail.
都被锁在那个房间里。然后她们在夜间陆续消失了。我过去常常回来向同一个女孩收集数据，因为你知道，在研究中你需要从同一组人那里收集数据。当我回去收集数据时，有些人已经不在了。八个月后，当我离开那里时，他们甚至让我签了一份文件，承诺不会泄露我在监狱里发现的情况。
So in India, as in any country, for that matter, girls are used by dignitaries who come to the capital city of that country. It could be here, it could be Serbia, it could be anywhere in the world. Washington, D.C., five miles away from the capital building is what they call the track. kitty track, literally five miles from the Capitol building. And in that kitty track, you have young girls being trafficked. So it happens across the world. And at that time, I was so young myself, I was so innocent at that time. I didn't know.
在印度，就像在任何其他国家一样，女孩们会被来到该国首都的高官显贵们利用。这可能发生在这里，可能发生在塞尔维亚，也可能发生在世界任何地方。在华盛顿特区，距离国会大厦五英里远的地方，有一个被称为“小猫小径”（kitty track）的地方，离国会大厦真的只有五英里。在那条小径上，有年轻女孩被贩运。所以这种情况在世界各地都在发生。那时我太年轻了，也非常天真，我当时根本不知道。
So I guess that's really where I started working with victims of trafficking without knowing myself I was doing that. And then years later, when I came to this country, I was doing my doctorate in Vanderbiltz University. And then a little girl, a seven-year-old girl sat on my lap and she said, my touching me and I didn't know what that was that was that was my segue into the field of human trafficking into field of sexual abuse child sexual abuse I actually came to this country to learn more about intellectual and cognitive
我想这就是我开始与贩运受害者接触的起点，尽管当时我并不知道自己在做什么。多年后，当我来到美国，在范德比尔特大学攻读博士学位时，一个小女孩坐在我的膝盖上，她说……她触碰我，而我当时不知道那意味着什么。那是我进入人口贩运和儿童性虐待领域的一个契机。我其实是来美国学习更多关于智力和认知
neuropsychic work but I ended up doing child sexual abuse and forensic work because these kids were talking to me so then because these kids were communicating with me and they wouldn't talk to other people my professors and my supervisors said okay you know why don't you talk to these kids and I did, and then those children then started having to testify in court. So then I went with them to testify, and the rest, like this day, is history. And then I started working with foster kids because a lot of kids are sexually abused end up in foster kids.
神经心理学工作的，但最终我却从事了儿童性虐待和法医相关的工作，因为这些孩子在跟我交流。因为这些孩子愿意与我沟通，却不愿与其他人交谈，我的教授和导师就说：“好吧，你为什么不跟这些孩子谈谈呢？”我照做了，后来这些孩子开始需要在法庭上作证。于是我陪着她们去作证，剩下的事情，直到今天，都已成为历史。后来我开始与寄养儿童合作，因为很多遭受性虐待的孩子最终都会进入寄养系统。
And then years, about 15, 20 years later, no, 30 years ago, 25, 30 years ago, I had a family of four children in Gary, Indiana, and they were between seven years old, and the youngest was two, two, three years old. they were being asked to perform tricks with each other. So in Gary, one of the houses, it had like black windows. The windows were black paper put on the windows. And inside the stage like this, a little stage, chairs just like that, and people were paying $10 a piece
大约15到20年前，不，是30年前，25到30年前，我在印第安纳州加里市接触过一个有四个孩子的家庭，他们年龄在两岁到七岁之间。他们被迫互相表演“戏法”。在加里市，其中一栋房子的窗户上贴着黑纸。里面有一个小舞台，摆着椅子，人们每人支付10美元
to come in to watch these kids do tricks, what they call tricks on each other. So the parents were trafficking their own children. And at that time, we didn't call it trafficking. 30 years ago, you know, child sexual abuse, no one said it was human trafficking, right? So what we did was we called a child sexual abuse. I went to court the family for the first time in the history.
进来观看这些孩子表演，也就是他们所谓的互相表演“戏法”。所以是父母在贩运自己的孩子。当时我们并不称之为“贩运”。30年前，对于儿童性虐待，没人会说这是人口贩运，对吧？所以我们当时称之为儿童性虐待。我第一次在法庭上处理这个家庭的案件，这在历史上是第一次。
The father got 56 years in jail. They had a life sentence, mother and father. They both got life sentences, basically. And that was my very first case. And from then on, I started getting cases on child sexual abuse from across the country, testifying of wherever, you know, what was going on. A lot of them high profile cases involving people who are like brothers of judges and politicians,
那个父亲被判入狱56年。父母双方都被判了终身监禁，基本上是这样。那是我的第一个案件。从那以后，我开始接到全国各地关于儿童性虐待的案件，并为各种正在发生的事情作证。其中许多是高调案件，涉及法官和政客的兄弟、
sisters, so forth. So I got involved with all of that. And then about 10, 20 years ago, 15, 20 years ago, maybe, I had a young girl called me from Chicago. And I was at this time working in Indiana. And she called me and she said, Doc, come pick me up. And I was like, I'm not going to come pick me. you up, this is a foster child. I said, I'm not going to come pick you up, you know, go home.
姐妹等等。所以我卷入了所有这些事情。大约10到20年前，也许是15到20年前，一个年轻女孩从芝加哥给我打电话。当时我在印第安纳州工作。她打电话给我说：“医生，来接我。”我说：“我不会去接你，你是个寄养儿童。我不会去接你，回家去。”
What are you doing at nine o'clock at night outside and get back home? What I didn't know is that she was probably being trafficked. I had no clue. Until today, that weighs on my mind as a child I could not protect. So from then on, I got really interested in the field of human trafficking because I realized these teenagers were disappearing. And what's really troubling is foster parents, some foster parents, not all, but some foster parents literally will ask for teenage children and teenage girls because I really get along well with the girls, you know, I'm really good with girls, I work really well with them, give me the teenagers, the hard to place, they're really hard to place, they're really hard to place, they're hard to place kids, we'll take care of them.
“你晚上九点在外面干什么？快回家！”我当时不知道的是，她可能正在被贩运。我一点头绪都没有。直到今天，这件事仍压在我的心头，因为我没能保护好那个孩子。从那时起，我开始对人口贩运领域产生浓厚兴趣，因为我意识到这些青少年正在消失。真正令人不安的是，有些寄养父母——不是全部，但有些——会专门要求领养十几岁的孩子和女孩，因为他们会说：“我真的很擅长和女孩相处，我工作做得很好，把那些难安置的青少年交给我吧，我们会照顾好她们。”
Of course these kids are running away, or we think they're running away, but now I realize they're probably being trafficked. So having done all these years of child sexual abuse, I was now moving into the field of human trafficking. So at this point, I do literally 20% or 30% on my clinical work is on human trafficking work, which are anti-human trafficking work. Can you help listeners understand what human trafficking is? Because you're talking a lot about sex trafficking, but trafficking can involve laborers as well. So can you help people understand sort of the range of what human trafficking encompasses? I'm really glad you asked me that the sex trafficking
当然，这些孩子会逃跑，或者我们以为她们是逃跑，但现在我意识到她们很可能被贩运了。在处理了这么多年的儿童性虐待案件后，我开始转向人口贩运领域。目前，我大约20%到30%的临床工作是关于人口贩运的，也就是反人口贩运工作。你能帮听众理解什么是人口贩运吗？因为你谈了很多关于性贩运的内容，但贩运也可能涉及劳工。你能帮大家理解人口贩运涵盖的范围吗？我很高兴你问我这个问题。性贩运
is like the sexy thing that people talk about, right? No pun intended. But, but So there's two types of trafficking, fundamentally. There's labor trafficking and there's sex trafficking. Labor trafficking is larger worldwide than sex trafficking. So labor trafficking is a $150 billion industry, right? Human trafficking is about 20% of all trafficking, sex trafficking that is. It's 20% of all trafficking.
是人们谈论最多的“热门”话题，对吧？没有双关的意思。但实际上，贩运主要有两种类型：劳工贩运和性贩运。在全球范围内，劳工贩运的规模比性贩运更大。劳工贩运是一个价值1500亿美元的产业。人口贩运中，性贩运大约占所有贩运案件的20%。
Labor trafficking involves organ harvesting. So I was in India training the people, the NGOs, and the Miramar, the Myanmar, Myanmar, Nepal, India border. There's a lot of unrest there. There's a lot of refugees out there. So I was working out there with the NGOs and the magistrates and the IOM, the UN people. And I was training them on how do you identify and work with victims of traffic.
劳工贩运还涉及器官摘取。我曾在印度培训非政府组织（NGO）的人员，地点在缅甸、尼泊尔和印度的边境。那里局势动荡，有很多难民。我当时在那里与非政府组织、地方法官以及国际移民组织（IOM）和联合国的工作人员合作，培训他们如何识别和帮助贩运受害者。
Because we're a psychologist, that's what we do. We train people to interview other people and to interact and to establish that rapport. And so when I was working with them, one of the things that comes up was organizing. harvesting, child brides, huge, huge issue of child brides, organ harvesting. Sex tourism is very big. So especially Thailand, the Philippines, Malaysia, Vietnam, there's a massive sex tourism. We have brides going from China to Vietnam. We have brides coming from Nepal to India, Russia to India.
因为我们是心理学家，这就是我们的工作。我们培训人们如何采访他人、如何互动并建立信任关系。当我与他们合作时，出现的问题之一就是器官摘取、童养媳（这是一个非常非常严重的问题）和器官摘取。性旅游也非常普遍。特别是在泰国、菲律宾、马来西亚和越南，存在大规模的性旅游。我们有从中国去往越南的“新娘”，也有从尼泊尔去往印度、从俄罗斯去往印度的“新娘”。
So these are child brides that are being trafficked. That's very, very big. Even in this country, we have child brides, and there's laws. Every state doesn't have laws against child brides, just so you know. Some of the states allow child brides. So keep that in mind when you think about human trafficking.
这些都是被贩运的童养媳。这非常非常普遍。即使在美国，也有童养媳现象，而且法律并不完善。你要知道，并非每个州都有禁止童养媳的法律。有些州允许童养媳存在。所以当你思考人口贩运时，请记住这一点。
Another big aspect of human trafficking is the mining industry. So for example, in DRC, which is DR Congo, in Africa, they have a region called Kivu, and we were working with some of the folks out there. And what happens is there's tin. They have mining with tin mining. tin mining. And the children and the women are trafficked for tin mining over there. So it's a very
人口贩运的另一个重要方面是采矿业。例如，在非洲的刚果民主共和国（DRC），有一个叫基伍（Kivu）的地区，我们曾与那里的一些人合作。那里有锡矿开采。孩子们和妇女被贩运去从事锡矿开采。所以这是一个
big industry all over the world. We have child soldiers in Kenya. So these kids are about three, four years old when these boys are then taken into human trafficking. They are child soldiers, and they're made to fight for ISIS. They're taken all over the world. So think of the Boko Haram children, the girls who were kidnapped, everyone knows about that. They were also trafficked, sexually trafficked, but they're also labor trafficked. Labor trafficking is huge between Nigeria and Italy. So Italy is a destination point, is a gateway into Europe, and they go from Libya and Nigeria. They go from Nigeria to Libya to Italy. So we are trying to break that chain. It's a supply demand chain. So the U.S. is a destination country for sex trafficking. The Middle East is a destination country for
遍布全球的庞大产业。在肯尼亚有童兵。这些男孩在三四岁时就被带走进行人口贩运。他们成为童兵，被迫为“伊斯兰国”（ISIS）作战。他们被带往世界各地。想想博科圣地（Boko Haram）的孩子们，那些被绑架的女孩，每个人都知道这件事。她们不仅被性贩运，也被劳工贩运。尼日利亚和意大利之间的劳工贩运非常严重。意大利是一个目的地，是进入欧洲的门户，他们从利比亚和尼日利亚出发。他们从尼日利亚经利比亚到达意大利。我们正试图打破这条链条。这是一个供需链。美国是性贩运的目的地国家。中东是
labor trafficking. Europe is a destination continent for sex and labor trafficking. So there's several different forms of it. Sex tourism, if you ever travel to the middle, to the southeastern countries, sex tourism is very big and their sex extortion is very good, very big there. So tourists go from here, they think, okay, you know what, my wife's not here, my family, my spouse, my girlfriend, whatever is not there. And what they do, pictures are taken and this extortion that takes place using the children. So there's a lot of pedophilia that goes on. Wow.
劳工贩运的目的地国家。欧洲是性贩运和劳工贩运的目的地大陆。所以它有几种不同的形式。性旅游，如果你去过东南亚国家，性旅游非常普遍，那里的性勒索也非常严重。游客从这里过去，他们想：“好吧，反正我妻子不在，我的家人、配偶、女朋友都不在。”于是他们拍下照片，利用孩子进行勒索。所以那里存在大量的恋童癖行为。哇。
It's a huge problem. I was researching this issue. I was overwhelmed by how big it is. And it happens not only across borders, but within countries as well. And it was important. I learned something important is that distinct from smuggling. Yes. Human smuggling is trying to get people into a country, not necessarily for labor or sex purposes.
这是一个巨大的问题。我研究过这个问题，被它的规模之大所震撼。它不仅跨越国界，在各国国内也同样存在。我学到了一件重要的事情，那就是它与“偷渡”是有区别的。是的。人口偷渡是指试图将人带入一个国家，而不一定是为了劳工或性目的。
Absolutely. This is really about getting people into the country to have them being used and really kept to do things that they don't want to be doing in a way that we would consider violation of their human rights. That's very well said because human smuggling involves money at the receiving end. So basically, you pay someone fully aware of what's happening. You talk about informed consent all the time, right? They are consenting to be smuggled across borders. Human trafficking doesn't involve any consent. It involves deception.
绝对是这样。人口贩运的核心是把人带入某个地方，让他们被利用，并被迫做他们不想做的事情，这在某种程度上被我们视为对人权的侵犯。说得很好，因为人口偷渡在接收端涉及金钱交易。基本上，你是在完全知情的情况下付钱给某人。我们经常谈论“知情同意”，对吧？他们同意被偷渡过境。而人口贩运不涉及任何同意。它涉及欺骗。
So it's fraud, coercion, deception. You're not paying money to be trafficked. Right. The trafficker gets paid to traffic you. It's a whole different dynamic. I can only imagine, and I want to know more about what's the psychological impact of having been trafficked? What happens to the person who is? It is massive.
所以它是欺诈、胁迫和欺骗。你不需要付钱被贩运。没错。是贩运者收钱来贩运你。这完全是不同的动态。我只能想象，我想更多地了解被贩运后的心理影响是什么？受害者会经历什么？影响是巨大的。
It is totally, and I tell people, you talk about domestic violence, right? And we talk about human trafficking. And people often think, well, I have a domestic violence shelter. Why can't I keep kids or women who are trafficked in that shelter? You can't. Because a domestic violence victim can walk out. A human trafficking victim should not be allowed to walk out because when they walk out, they go to their trafficker.
这是彻底的。我告诉人们，你们谈论家庭暴力，对吧？我们谈论人口贩运。人们通常认为：“好吧，我有一个家庭暴力避难所，为什么我不能把被贩运的孩子或妇女安置在那里？”你不能。因为家庭暴力受害者可以走出来。而人口贩运受害者不应该被允许随意走出来，因为当她们走出来时，她们会回到贩运者身边。
Immediately the traffickers waiting outside. And they're terrified, terrified of speaking, Because even though you and I are talking, if you have a victim of human trafficking in front of us, it's just not three of us. Her traffickers in the room with her. He's psychologically right there. So it's a manipulation. It's a dehumanization of an individual with, it's almost like an addictive force. So what they do, they'll give you little bits of love.
贩运者会立刻在外面等着。她们害怕说话，因为即使你和我正在交谈，如果我们面前有一个人口贩运受害者，那不仅仅是我们三个人。她的贩运者就在房间里。他在心理上就在那里。这是一种操纵。这是一种对个人的非人化，几乎像是一种成瘾力量。所以他们会怎么做？他们会给你一点点爱。
Teeny, meaning, you know, you're great, you're beautiful, you're lovely, a little bit of love. And then massive doses of punishment. You know, there's pain through the cigarette butts being put on them. They're made to lay naked on a table. And so as an example to everybody else who spoke or snitched, you know, basically, they beat them up. So if you don't bring X number of dollars home to the trafficker that day, you're on serious punishment.
一点点，意思是：“你很棒，你很美，你很可爱。”给一点点爱。然后是大量的惩罚。你知道，通过烟头烫伤她们来施加痛苦。她们被迫赤身裸体躺在桌子上。作为对其他任何说话或告密的人的惩戒，基本上，他们会殴打她们。所以如果你那天没有给贩运者带回一定数额的钱，你就会受到严重的惩罚。
There's no food, there's no water, there's no drink. There's nothing for you. It's a very seriously dehumanization. So your entire identity is what the trafficker tells you you are. If the trafficker says you're a woman, you're a woman. If traffic says, you know, it's that bad. It's that severe. It's a complete manipulation control of the human mind.
没有食物，没有水，没有饮料。什么都没有。这是一种非常严重的非人化。所以你的整个身份就是贩运者告诉你你是谁。如果贩运者说你是女人，你就是女人。如果贩运者说……情况就是那么糟糕。就是那么严重。这是对人类思想的完全操纵和控制。
And how does a person ever get out of that? What is it that they can do to try to escape that manipulation? Is there something? There's so much now. As psychologists, we have so much to offer. And the tragedy in this field, and I say it's a tragedy, because there's not enough psychologists who are involved because you always think of it as a social justice issues social work issue what am I doing with community stuff you know that
一个人怎么能摆脱那种状态？她们能做些什么来尝试逃避那种操纵？有什么办法吗？现在有很多办法。作为心理学家，我们能提供很多帮助。这个领域的悲剧——我称之为悲剧——是因为参与其中的心理学家不够多，因为人们总是认为这是一个社会正义问题、社会工作问题，“我做社区工作干什么？”你知道，
that kind of mentality we tend to be more clinically in our office in a in a clinic safe like a comfort zone being in your office but really we need to get out there in the community because that's really where human trafficking is happening that's where our patients are our patients are in the community they're living every day in the community they're not living in our office right So we need to be out there. And so the ways to treat victims of human trafficking, what I do, I had to modify existing treatment to work with trauma victims of human trafficking.
那种心态。我们倾向于在办公室或诊所里进行临床工作，待在舒适区。但实际上，我们需要走到社区中去，因为人口贩运真正发生的地方就在那里，我们的病人就在那里。她们每天生活在社区里，而不是生活在我们的办公室里。所以我们需要走出去。治疗人口贩运受害者的方法，我所做的是，我必须修改现有的治疗方法来应对人口贩运的创伤受害者。
Because you're working with an addictive or an addicted human being. You're also working with a human being who doesn't feel she's human anymore. Because the traffickers who gives her her identity. So when you have that third person in the room, you first have to separate that literally, that literally the psychological separation between the trafficker and her like two separate entities that's the first stage and the next stage then is then you try to tell this person who are you then you have to build you're to build that person up not only as a human being but you to build them up and says what do I want
因为你面对的是一个成瘾或被成瘾的人。你面对的也是一个不再觉得自己是人类的人。因为是贩运者赋予了她身份。所以当房间里有那个“第三者”时，你首先必须在心理上将贩运者和她分离开来，就像两个独立的实体，这是第一阶段。下一阶段，你再尝试告诉这个人：“你是谁？”然后你必须建立……你必须建立起那个人，不仅是作为一个人类，你必须建立她们，并问：“我想要什么？”
what do I like who am I who was I before I became a victim of trafficking I became of my PIMS girl you know they have have, they identify themselves with a lot of street language, which I won't use, but they have very specific language how they identify themselves. They have a hierarchy. It's like a harem, so each woman has a role in that harem. And then I do a lot of trauma work with rapid resolution therapy. I've modified some of the treatments because I do Eastern as well as Western, because it's not only a psychological issue, it's a spiritual emotion, it's just a multifaceted demeaning of a person. I've never seen a human being so non-human as I've seen
“我喜欢什么？我是谁？在我成为贩运受害者之前我是谁？”她们用很多街头语言来定义自己，我不会在这里使用，但她们有非常具体的语言来定义自己。她们有等级制度。就像后宫一样，每个女人在那个后宫里都有一个角色。然后我用“快速解决疗法”（Rapid Resolution Therapy）做很多创伤工作。我修改了一些治疗方法，因为我结合了东方和西方的疗法，因为这不仅是一个心理问题，它是一个精神情感问题，是对一个人多方面的贬低。我从未见过像
the victims of trafficking. Wow. It is they will sit in my office and I worked with severe sexual abuse so don't get me wrong. I've worked with very very severe sexual abuse cases with you know the fragments of personalities do and so they will sit here they will put their legs up there and they will just hold themselves like this for hours and you cannot speak to them because in their heads, their traffickers looking right at them. And they're not hallucinating. That person's in their head, you know, literally inside the head.
贩运受害者那样被非人化的人。哇。她们会坐在我的办公室里。我处理过严重的性虐待案件，所以别误会。我处理过非常非常严重的性虐待案件，你知道，人格碎片化的情况。她们会坐在那里，把腿蜷起来，就这样抱着自己几个小时，你无法与她们交谈，因为在她们脑海里，贩运者正盯着她们看。她们不是在产生幻觉。那个人就在她们脑子里，字面意义上就在脑子里。
So you're working with an individual who's so severely traumatized, you know, it's just a tragedy. And so when you have to pull them out, the biggest thing, what I use, I use a lot of visual, tactile and very hands-on with them. You know, usually with trauma patients, you say, don't touch them, don't go near. them. With them, they literally need you to hold them. You literally have to hold them. You know, like they're like children. And once they trust you, initially they won't talk, of course, but once they trust you, you can't stop them. It's like a dam just breaks through and they cry and cry and cry and they'll talk and talk and talk. A session with them is about three hours.
所以你面对的是一个受到严重创伤的个体，这真是一场悲剧。所以当你必须把她们拉出来时，我使用的方法是大量的视觉、触觉和非常亲身的接触。你知道，通常对于创伤病人，你会说：“不要碰她们，不要靠近她们。”但对于她们，她们确实需要你拥抱她们。你真的必须拥抱她们。你知道，她们就像孩子一样。一旦她们信任你，起初她们当然不会说话，但一旦她们信任你，你就无法阻止她们。就像大坝决堤一样，她们会哭个不停，然后她们会说个不停。与她们的一次会谈大约需要三个小时。
You can go shorter than three hours because there's so much they've held in. But if you say, I'm sorry, you know, my time's up, you know, you need to go, my patients waiting outside. You've lost them, they're not coming back. Right, and they would need time to sort of get out, but then to be safe enough to then leave your office, I would imagine. Absolutely, absolutely. You can't do traditional EMDR, you can't do traditional rapid resolution, you can't do traditional, visual therapy, you can't do the traditional narrative.
你不能少于三个小时，因为她们压抑了太多东西。但如果你说：“对不起，我的时间到了，你需要离开，我的病人还在外面等着。”你就失去了她们，她们不会再回来了。没错，她们需要时间走出来，但要足够安全才能离开你的办公室，我想象是这样。绝对是。你不能做传统的眼动脱敏再加工疗法（EMDR），你不能做传统的快速解决疗法，你不能做传统的视觉疗法，你不能做传统的叙事疗法。
So I've had to modify everything I've learned in order to be able to reach out to them. So I modified it. For example, rapid resolution therapy, which is like a visual hypnosis kind of therapy. I call it the chakra, rapid resolution chakra therapy. So I put them into deep relaxation. And I literally do work that I've never done before in my life, but I have to do it because that's what works.
所以我必须修改我所学的一切，以便能够触及她们。所以我修改了它。例如，快速解决疗法，这是一种视觉催眠疗法。我称之为“脉轮快速解决疗法”（chakra rapid resolution therapy）。所以我让她们进入深度放松状态。我确实做了我一生中从未做过的工作，但我必须这样做，因为这才是有效的。
So ultimately, when we're looking at our patients and we're saying we need to do evidence-based work, I say, yeah, sure, let's do evidence-based work. I'm all for it. But what do I do with this patient who is not going to respond to it? You know, I can't just say, hey, by the way, this is my technique. I'm going to use it because I know it's backed by serious scientific research.
所以最终，当我们审视我们的病人并说我们需要做循证工作时，我说：“是的，当然，让我们做循证工作。”我完全支持。但对于这个不会对此做出反应的病人，我该怎么办？你知道，我不能只是说：“嘿，顺便说一下，这是我的技术。我要用它，因为我知道它有严谨的科学研究支持。”
Can't. You have to heal your patients, right? That's what we are sworn to do. So I modify a lot of those techniques. And now my patients, within about four sessions, I'm able to get them to speak. I'm able to get them to write. Because sometimes they will refuse to write. They're frightened to write.
不能这样做。你必须治愈你的病人，对吧？这是我们宣誓要做的事情。所以我修改了许多那些技术。现在我的病人，大约四次会谈后，我就能让她们开口说话。我能让她们写东西。因为有时她们会拒绝写。她们害怕写。
I'm able to separate them from the trafficker with that huge guilt. It's like this massive shift. and guilt because once they get better, once they realize the victims, and they, by the way, they never think of themselves as victims. They think of themselves as just being the girlfriend. So if he go there and say, I'm so sorry, you're victimized by human trafficking and this guy is your pimp, she doesn't know, he's not my pen. I'm doing this because I want to do it.
我能够用那种巨大的内疚感将她们与贩运者分离开来。这是一种巨大的转变。内疚感，因为一旦她们好转，一旦她们意识到自己是受害者——顺便说一下，她们从不认为自己是受害者。她们认为自己只是“女朋友”。所以如果你走过去说：“我很抱歉，你受到了人口贩运的伤害，这个家伙是你的皮条客。”她不知道，“他不是我的皮条客。我做这个是因为我想做。”
And if he's my pimp, it's because I chose him to be my pen. So how do individuals find their way to you if they're not seeing themselves as being trafficked? Usually I'll get them from the FBI. I get them from the Homeland Security Department. I get them from the Sheriff's Department. So the deputies in the Sheriff's Department will send them to me. Other survivors will send them to me.
“如果他是我的皮条客，那是因为我选择让他成为我的皮条客。”那么，如果个人不认为自己被贩运，她们是如何找到你的呢？通常我是从联邦调查局（FBI）那里接到她们。我从国土安全部接到她们。我从治安官部门接到她们。所以治安官部门的副警长会把她们送到我这里。其他幸存者也会把她们介绍给我。
They're not NGOs. They send them, yeah. So I get them from a variety of different. So how can the average person recognize whether or not someone's being trafficked when the person themselves doesn't necessarily recognize it? Absolutely. So, you know, in the statistics we have in Indiana, for example, is like 159 cases were reported last year.
她们不是非政府组织。他们把她们送来，是的。所以我从各种不同的渠道接到她们。那么普通人如何识别某人是否正在被贩运，而当事人自己却不一定意识到呢？绝对是这样。所以，你知道，以印第安纳州的统计数据为例，去年报告了159起案件。
In my clinic alone, I had six cases in two months that identified. So think about if someone is not trained, just like I wasn't years ago, I had to train myself. If someone's not trained, as a psychologist, we'll miss all the signs. So this is what you're looking for. You're going to be looking for people with extra phones.
仅在我的诊所里，我在两个月内就识别出了六起案件。所以想想看，如果一个人没有受过训练，就像我多年前一样——我不得不自己训练自己——如果一个人没有受过训练，作为心理学家，我们会错过所有的迹象。所以这就是你要寻找的。你要寻找那些有额外手机的人。
Someone whose hygiene is questionable. someone who's got problems of running away from home several times. So within 48 hours of a kid being picked up by running away, one in five to six children is picked up by a trafficker. That is the high statistic we have. We have 458,000 missing children in the country, right?
那些卫生状况堪忧的人。那些有多次离家出走问题的人。在孩子因离家出走被带走后的48小时内，五到六个孩子中就有一个会被贩运者带走。这就是我们掌握的高统计数据。我们国家有45.8万名失踪儿童，对吧？
But Nick Mech, which is a national missing, exploited children, they have identified about 459,000 children, I think, as it last year. But when they did the Super Bowl, and during the Super Bowl, they rescued children. They were able to identify only 10% from the missing children's database. Wow. 90% they didn't even know what missing.
但是国家失踪与受剥削儿童中心（NCMEC），他们去年识别出了大约45.9万名儿童。但在超级碗期间，他们营救了儿童。他们只能从失踪儿童数据库中识别出10%。哇。90%的人甚至不知道他们失踪了。
Wow. That's huge. That's huge. It's huge. So people who are being trafficked don't necessarily recognize it. It's very hard for us to recognize that people are being trafficked. Yes. What does someone who has been trafficked, if they get out of the situation,
哇。这太严重了。这太严重了。太严重了。所以被贩运的人不一定意识到这一点。我们很难识别出人们正在被贩运。是的。如果一个被贩运的人逃离了那种处境，
What is it that they can do or what seems to help them to rebuild their lives? So what really helps them is jobs. So one of the biggest things I've got from survivors, the biggest complaints we have from survivors, because I host a conference every year on human trafficking, is because the very first conference we had in 2014, we had eight survivors there, and all eight of them had said, please give us jobs. Don't just tell us you're going to get us out of this life.
她们能做些什么，或者什么有助于她们重建生活？真正帮助她们的是工作。所以从幸存者那里我得到的最重要的事情之一——因为我每年都举办关于人口贩运的会议——我们最大的抱怨来自幸存者，因为我们在2014年举办的第一次会议上，有八位幸存者在那里，她们八个人都说：“请给我们工作。不要只是告诉我们你会把我们从这种生活中救出来。”
They call it the life. is it don't get us out of the life. Give us jobs. Because if you have jobs, we won't go back. But if I can't pay my rent, I can't put food on the table, you know, I can't buy a small toy for my grandchild, I can't do all of that.
她们称之为“那种生活”（the life）。“不要只是把我们从那种生活中救出来。给我们工作。”因为如果你有工作，我们就不会回去。但如果我付不起房租，我买不起食物，你知道，我不能给我的孙子买个小玩具，我什么都做不了。
How do you want me to survive? At least my PIM, sorry, you know, that's what they call them, at least my PIM gives me the money that I can, you know, survive. I can send money home if I have to. So the way to identify these victims in a clinic setting ask them three questions just three if you can ask these three questions you can actually identify victims one who's in charge
你想要我怎么生存？至少我的皮条客——抱歉，你知道，她们就是这么称呼他们的——至少我的皮条客给了我钱，让我可以生存。如果需要的话，我可以寄钱回家。所以，在临床环境中识别这些受害者的办法是问她们三个问题，就三个。如果你能问这三个问题，你实际上就能识别出受害者。第一，谁在掌管
of your money who's in charge of your money if you're an adult right who's in charge of your money if you're in a domestic violence condition for a situation maybe your spouse is in charge of your money or the guy who's your boyfriend so then you want to ask more questions has he made you sleep with other men simple questions right there's one question Lisa next question least the third. So just the classic interviewing technique that we're really well trained to do. And then the second question you always want to ask is, have you been made to do something you didn't want to do? Have you had to do something you didn't want to do? It could be, yeah, I didn't want to go to the mall, so I had to go to the mall.
你的钱？谁在掌管你的钱？如果你是成年人，对吧？谁在掌管你的钱？如果你处于家庭暴力的情况下，也许是你的配偶在掌管你的钱，或者是你的男朋友。所以你想问更多的问题：“他有没有强迫你和别的男人睡觉？”简单的问题，对吧？这是一个问题。下一个问题。第三个问题。所以这就是我们受过良好训练的经典采访技巧。然后第二个问题你总是想问：“你有没有被迫做过你不想做的事情？你有没有不得不做过你不想做的事情？”可能是：“是的，我不想去商场，但我不得不去商场。”
Anything else that caused you shame or made you feel bad about yourself, about your body. So you can ask questions that lead to more deeper questions. And it's like the funnel approach and interview that we do. We ask broad questions and then we narrow it down. And the third question you can always ask, especially of a child abuse, child sexual abuse victim, did you ever feel bad about sleeping with this person? Usually it's a mother's boyfriend. Because the mother knows that you had sex with the boyfriend
任何其他让你感到羞耻或让你对自己、对你的身体感到糟糕的事情。所以你可以问一些引导出更深层问题的问题。这就像我们采访中使用的漏斗法。我们问广泛的问题，然后缩小范围。第三个问题你总是可以问，特别是对儿童性虐待受害者：“你有没有因为和这个人睡觉而感到难过？”通常是母亲的男朋友。因为母亲知道你和男朋友发生了性关系，
or the husband, because in exchange, she was able to pay rent. That is human traffic. That literally is human trafficking, but we don't call it that. The mother trafficked the child in order to pay rent for the other kids and herself. So clearly with trafficking, and certainly you're talking a lot about sex trafficking, the inability to provide basic things. Absolutely. It's the financial motivator in many ways.
或者丈夫，因为作为交换，她能够支付房租。这就是人口贩运。这字面上就是人口贩运，但我们不这样称呼它。母亲贩运了孩子以支付其他孩子和她自己的房租。所以很明显，在贩运中，当然你谈了很多关于性贩运，无法提供基本生活需求。绝对是。这在很多方面是经济动机。
I mean, obviously, one person is benefiting financially, and one person's barely surviving. Absolutely. But that's part of what's happening. Absolutely. The first question you asked, said you should ask is, who's controlling the money? I suspect that's also really relevant for people who are being labor trafficked as well. Absolutely. And are there things to look out for for people who are being labor traffic that might
我的意思是，显然，一个人在经济上受益，而另一个人勉强生存。绝对是。但这是正在发生的事情的一部分。绝对是。你问的第一个问题，你说应该问的是：“谁在控制钱？”我怀疑这对于那些被劳工贩运的人来说也是非常相关的。绝对是。对于那些被劳工贩运的人，有什么需要注意的迹象吗？这可能
be different from sex trafficking? So labor trafficking has a very different dynamic than sex trafficking. We don't see many in the clinical setting for labor trafficking, right? Because labor trafficking tends to be domestic servitude. So in domestic servitude, for example, they'll have small children who are in the clinical who are sent by their parents to work in your house in exchange for all the income that she makes going back to the family.
与性贩运不同？所以劳工贩运的动态与性贩运非常不同。我们在临床环境中看不到很多劳工贩运的案例，对吧？因为劳工贩运往往是家庭奴役。例如，在家庭奴役中，他们会有被父母送来在你家里工作的小孩，作为交换，她赚的所有收入都回到了家庭。
So in certain situations, for example, with labor trafficking, usually with organ harvesting, for me that's like really big, because that's one of the biggest forms of labor trafficking. What happens with organ harvesting is in order to go from one country, for example, to come to from Mexico to the US, US, right? Think about labor trafficking when you think about that. I know we focus on sex
所以在某些情况下，例如劳工贩运，通常涉及器官摘取，对我来说这非常严重，因为这是劳工贩运最大的形式之一。器官摘取发生的情况是，为了从一个国家，例如从墨西哥来到美国，对吧？当你想到劳工贩运时，想想这个。我知道我们关注性
trafficking a lot, but that's with the minors. But with the older people, the older adults, labor trafficking would be where they take an organ in exchange for safe passage of your family. So for example, a kidney, if I don't know any of you have families with kidney failure, but with a kidney that's donated, there is a cost to it. So if you give me your kidney, I will allow your wife and child, one child, to come across the border. You have to give me something else
贩运很多，但那是针对未成年人的。但对于年长的人，成年人，劳工贩运可能是他们摘取一个器官以换取你家人的安全通行。例如，一个肾脏。我不知道你们中是否有人有肾衰竭的家人，但捐赠的肾脏是有成本的。所以如果你给我你的肾脏，我会允许你的妻子和一个孩子，一个孩子，过境。你必须给我其他东西
in order for your other child to come across the border. And that child becomes the unaccompanied minors. So between January and June, we had 56,000 children unaccompanied. in the border. In May alone we had 11,500 children who were unaccompanied. So this is a massive, massive human trafficking racket. The proportions I can't even explain to you how seriously they impact families within this country as well. Because think about these kids are going to school with your kids. These kids are intermingling
为了让你另一个孩子过境。而那个孩子就成了无人陪伴的未成年人。所以从一月到六月，我们在边境有5.6万名无人陪伴的儿童。仅在五月，我们就有一万一千五百名无人陪伴的儿童。所以这是一个大规模、大规模的人口贩运集团。我甚至无法向你解释这些比例对这个国家内部的家庭造成了多么严重的冲击。因为想想看，这些孩子和你的孩子一起上学。这些孩子正在与
with your kids. They're then being hired by traffickers to then say, hey, go to the school and get these other kids to upload pictures of themselves. So labor and sex trafficking then gets intertwined. So it's a very fine line between the two, and often they go together. Labor and sex trafficking, very frequently go hand in hand. So these are things we start to tell people to think about, because nowadays with the Internet and the digital age, the biggest problem we are having now is our middle schoolers are being asked to
你的孩子混在一起。他们然后被贩运者雇佣，说：“嘿，去学校，让这些其他孩子上传他们自己的照片。”所以劳工贩运和性贩运就交织在一起了。所以两者之间界限非常模糊，而且它们经常同时发生。劳工贩运和性贩运非常频繁地齐头并进。所以这些是我们开始告诉人们去思考的事情，因为现在有了互联网和数字时代，我们现在面临的最大问题是我们的初中生被要求
upload pictures of themselves with nothing much on. And then they're saying, if you're my friend, you'll send me a picture. Before it was, if you're my friend, you'll wear the same color clothes I wear. You know, now it is, if you're my friend, you'll upload a picture of yourself doing X, Y, Z. So these kids do that just because they don't want
上传他们自己几乎没穿衣服的照片。然后他们说：“如果你是我的朋友，你就会发给我一张照片。”以前是：“如果你是我的朋友，你就会穿和我一样颜色的衣服。”你知道，现在是：“如果你是我的朋友，你就会上传一张你做某某事的照片。”所以这些孩子这样做只是因为他们不想
to lose the friendship. And because everybody else is doing it. So of course they're going to do it. And then after some time they say, I don't want to do it again. Oops, too late. I have your picture. I'm going to show it to your mother. or your father, or the whole school's going to know what you did.
失去友谊。而且因为其他人都在这样做。所以他们当然会这样做。然后过了一段时间，他们说：“我不想再做了。”哎呀，太晚了。我有你的照片。我要把它展示给你妈妈，或者你爸爸，或者全校都会知道你做了什么。
And from then on, they're trapped. Right, so there's a way that now media, technology, is really contributing to individuals in this country, getting brought into maybe not actually performing sexual acts, but providing pornography because they're being manipulated. I hadn't realized that was happening as well. It's horrifying to think about that. It's horrifying, horrifying.
从那时起，他们就被困住了。没错，所以现在媒体、技术确实在导致这个国家的人们被带入，也许不是真的进行性行为，而是提供色情内容，因为他们被操纵了。我没意识到这也正在发生。想到这一点真是令人毛骨悚然。这真是令人毛骨悚然，毛骨悚然。
What else do you think people should know about trafficking and how psychology can help people in that space? So I think the biggest, what I really like for everyone to know about human trafficking is that it's here. It's happening here. It's happening among us. It happens in meetings. I host a conference, like I said, on human trafficking. I had somebody come in 2014, my 2014, my first conference, and the guy had an NGO. that are volunteers. You know how you have nonprofit organizations and they're like, let's, you need to volunteer. Why don't you volunteer in this organization? Or they'll say, you know,
你认为人们还应该了解关于贩运的什么，以及心理学如何能在那个领域帮助人们？所以我认为关于人口贩运，我真正希望每个人都知道的是，它就在这里。它正在这里发生。它就在我们中间发生。它在会议中发生。我举办了一个会议，就像我说的，关于人口贩运。我在2014年，我的2014年，我的第一次会议上，有人来了，那个人有一个非政府组织。
we are a modeling agency. You know, you have a pretty daughter or you're pretty yourself or good looking yourself. They'll say, hey, would you like to model? And then they'll take your picture and they say they're going to model you. That picture, your face goes on somebody else's body. Or they'll make you say do certain poses and they'll put that and they can digitally change you so that you are actually performing an act. And then they'll send that picture back to you, the video back to you, and say, if you don't do what I tell you or you don't service so into person, I'm going to send this to whoever you're married to.
那是志愿者。你知道你们有非营利组织，他们会说：“来吧，你需要做志愿者。你为什么不来这个组织做志愿者？”或者他们会说：“我们是一家模特经纪公司。你知道，你有一个漂亮的女儿，或者你自己很漂亮，或者你自己长得好看。”他们会说：“嘿，你想当模特吗？”然后他们会拍你的照片，他们说他们要让你当模特。那张照片，你的脸被放在了别人的身体上。或者他们会让你做某些姿势，他们会拍下来，他们可以数字化地改变你，让你看起来真的在表演某种行为。然后他们会把那张照片发回给你，把视频发回给你，说：“如果你不按我说的做，或者你不服务某人，我就把这个发给你结婚的对象。”
And imagine you're married, you have children, you have a family, and you just say, okay, I want to make some extra money, I want to do some modeling. I work in a retail store. That's where they go, the malls. the malls, the schools, things that we think, the playgrounds, we think these are safe places, and they're generally safe if you're just alert to the science. So it seems that one of the challenges these days is that it's really, we have much less control over how our images projected, and that that can be used in manipulative ways that were not present
想象一下你已婚，有孩子，有家庭，你只是说，好吧，我想多赚点钱，我想做模特。我在零售店工作。这就是他们去的地方，商场、学校，我们认为安全的地方，比如游乐场，我们认为这些地方是安全的，如果你对迹象保持警惕，它们通常是安全的。所以现在的挑战之一似乎是，我们对自己的形象如何被投射的控制力大大减弱了，而且这些形象可能以过去不存在的方式被用于操纵。
20 years ago. So I would imagine that in the field of trafficking, particularly around sex trafficking, and labor trafficking. The technology that is being employed, law enforcement agencies have all sorts of new challenges in order to keep up with that. And in labor trafficking, usually the biggest problem we have is people come from other countries to safer countries, what they think is safer countries, for a better opportunity. You come for a better life for your children, unless you're a refugee. So there's two types of refugees, right?
20年前。所以我认为在人口贩运领域，特别是性贩运和劳工贩运方面，所采用的技术让执法机构面临各种新的挑战，以跟上这些变化。在劳工贩运中，我们通常面临的最大问题是人们从其他国家来到他们认为更安全的国家，以寻求更好的机会。除非你是难民，否则你来到这里是为了给你的孩子更好的生活。所以难民有两种，对吧？
one of the refugees who come to the country because they're escaping political conflict. They're political refugees. The other kind of refugees are those who are escaping poverty, and they want to come for a better life. So there's war conflict and politics, and then there is a need for economics. They're both economically challenging aspects. So when they come to this country or to any other country, that is doing better, or considered safer,
一种是因逃避政治冲突而来到这个国家的难民。他们是政治难民。另一种难民是那些为了逃避贫困，想要寻求更好生活的人。所以有战争冲突和政治因素，也有经济需求。它们都是具有经济挑战性的方面。因此，当他们来到这个国家或任何其他表现更好或被认为更安全的国家时，
quote-unquote, safer than their country, then what happens is they become at risk for labor trafficking. So oftentimes it's a job, it's a promise of a job. They'll say, you know what? You come there, you'll have a job waiting for you. You just have to turn in your papers. So the biggest aspect of the labor trafficking and sex trafficking is they'll take your papers from you.
所谓的“更安全”的国家，他们就会面临劳工贩运的风险。通常这是一份工作，一个工作承诺。他们会说，你知道吗？你到那里去，会有一份工作等着你。你只需要交出你的证件。所以劳工贩运和性贩运最大的方面就是他们会拿走你的证件。
Right. We'll keep your papers because we need to turn this over to the authorities. and we can convince them, you know, we can convince them that you're a good candidate for this job. So I need all your papers. Of course you're going to give your papers because you want to get that job. Or you want to be allowed in a new country. Once you arrive in the new country, you'll never get your papers back. So you have no papers, you have no identification.
没错。我们会保管你的证件，因为我们需要把它交给当局。我们可以说服他们，你知道，我们可以说服他们你是一个很好的工作人选。所以我需要你所有的证件。当然，你会交出你的证件，因为你想得到那份工作。或者你想被允许进入一个新的国家。一旦你到达新国家，你就再也拿不回你的证件了。所以你没有证件，没有身份证明。
You're basically, even though you may have come in legally at some level, you still have nothing. So that is a challenge between legal and illegal immigration. too for us because they have lost their papers because those papers get confiscated and that's a big problem with them what kinds of challenges or where would you hope that psychologists and people who are interested in psychology how could they use this information in the in their local communities really is raising awareness so what I do a lot of my work when I go talking churches you know I talk about psychological trauma I talk about identification I talk
你基本上，即使你在某种程度上是合法入境的，你仍然一无所有。所以这对我们来说是合法移民和非法移民之间的一个挑战，因为他们失去了证件，因为那些证件被没收了，这对他们来说是一个大问题。你希望心理学家和对心理学感兴趣的人如何利用这些信息在当地社区中发挥作用？其实就是提高意识。所以我做很多工作时，去教堂演讲，我谈论心理创伤，谈论身份识别，谈论
about child development. I talk about adolescent, so I have a whole curriculum I've developed. It's called the I Act Program. So we've now got accredited. As the first program, there's been accredited globally. And I've developed this program because we have 10 modules covering all the way from infancy, labor sex trafficking, all the, because people don't talk much about labor trafficking. So thank you so much for bringing it up again and again because it's so important. And labor trafficking, just remember, is larger, larger and more worldwide than what we experience in the U.S. as sex trafficking and labor trafficking. So keep that in mind.
儿童发展。我谈论青少年，所以我开发了一整套课程。它被称为“I Act”项目。我们现在已经获得了认证。作为第一个在全球范围内获得认证的项目。我开发这个项目是因为我们有10个模块，涵盖了从婴儿期到劳工和性贩运的所有内容，因为人们不太谈论劳工贩运。所以非常感谢你一次又一次地提出这个问题，因为它非常重要。请记住，劳工贩运比我们在美国所经历的性贩运和劳工贩运规模更大，范围更广。所以请记住这一点。
So that's one thing I really want to convey. But as psychologists, we can actually teach about child development. We can teach about the human brain. We can teach about the neuropsychological substrates of trauma. We can teach about how to treat trauma. There's so much rehab. So I'm building a village for human trafficking victims. And we're building it in Indiana.
所以这是我真正想传达的一点。但作为心理学家，我们实际上可以教授儿童发展知识。我们可以教授人类大脑的知识。我们可以教授创伤的神经心理学基础。我们可以教授如何治疗创伤。康复工作有很多。所以我正在为人口贩运受害者建立一个村庄。我们正在印第安纳州建设它。
And we have a whole restorative treatment, trauma-informed, trauma-based, evidence-based, and non-evidence-based treatment, where we are actually going to be having 100 children. And we're trying to raise $26 million, just so you know. So we try to raise all that money so we could build the very first human trafficking safe village that is actually built by psychologists, run by psychologists, and mental health professionals, and the vets are going to be providing us the security. So we are rehabilitating the vets, we are rehabilitating the children, and rehabilitating the youth and the mothers with children. So it's a very comprehensive program.
我们有一套完整的恢复性治疗，基于创伤知情、基于创伤、循证和非循证的治疗，我们实际上将容纳100名儿童。我们正在努力筹集2600万美元，只是让你知道。所以我们试图筹集所有这些资金，以便我们能够建立第一个由心理学家建造、由心理学家和心理健康专业人员运营的人口贩运安全村，退伍军人将为我们提供安全保障。所以我们正在帮助退伍军人康复，我们正在帮助儿童康复，帮助青少年和带着孩子的母亲康复。所以这是一个非常全面的项目。
Sounds like a really important vision for what you could do to benefit people who have them. That's really impressive. Thank you. Well, I'm so happy that you were able to join us today. Thank you for spending your time with us. Thank you. Thank you for listening to this podcast. This is APA's Speaking of Psychology Podcast.
听起来这是一个非常重要的愿景，可以造福那些有需要的人。这真的很令人印象深刻。谢谢。好吧，我很高兴你今天能加入我们。谢谢你花时间陪伴我们。谢谢。感谢收听本期播客。这是美国心理学会的“心理学谈话”播客。
If you have enjoyed the podcast or have any comments or ideas you want to share, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. You can find this podcast. on Stitcher, iTunes, or wherever you find your podcast, you can also visit our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org and listen to other episodes there as well. Again, I'm Dr. Lynn Bufka with the American Psychological Association. Thank you, everybody from here. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢这个播客，或者有任何想分享的评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。你可以在Stitcher、iTunes或任何你收听播客的地方找到这个播客，你也可以访问我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org，在那里收听其他剧集。再次重申，我是美国心理学会的Lynn Bufka博士。谢谢大家。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。